So you're probably saying so what? Why
would I want to reduce factors first?
Well, what if I wanted to find 3/10*5/12?
I could draw a diagram of the candy bar
and split up the pieces before it. I could
split up the 10's and then 12's. But
that's kind of a lot of work and I know I
just really need to multiply these 2
fractions. Multiplying these two fractions
together I get 15/120. But now
I have to figure out if I can simplify
this, and how to simplify this fraction.
This can be frustrating working with large
numbers, so let's make our work easier and
simplify our fractions first. I know 10
can be written as 2*5, and 12 can be
written as 3*4. Remember any number
divided by itself makes 1. Like 4/4 makes
1, 5/5 makes 1. It doesn't work for zero,
but we should keep this in mind when we're
simplifying. Here I have 3/3 so that makes
1 and 5/5, so that also makes 1. Now I'll
just multiply my numerators. So I have
1 times 1, which is 1 and I have 2 times 1 times 1 times 4 or I
have 2 times 1 times 1 times 4.
Which I know that's just really 2*4 or 8.
So 15/120 is really the same thing as
1/8th. I am showing you this longer method
so you can really see why we can cancel
factors. You can do ahead of the time and
this is what it would look like. I know 5
and 10 share a common factor of 5, so I
can divide them both by 5, 5/5 makes 1,
10/5 makes 2. 3 and 12 also share a factor
of 3, so 3/3 makes 1, and 12/3 makes 4.
Now, I multiply, just like before, 1*1 is
1, and 2*4 is 8. So either way I do it
this long way, or this shorter way with
cross-cancelling, I get 1/8.